Hello Fandango MOVIECLIPS, we are the Paz Brothers
directors of the biblical apocalypse film 'Jeruzalem'.
To get your primed and ready to check out 'Jeruzalem'
We're going to give you are top five favorite religious horror movies.
Number five on the list is 2009's 'Drag Me To Hell'.
An old woman curses Christine
Who must figure out how to rid herself of the demons that haunt her.
Directed by Sam Raimi, the mastermind behind the Evil Dead films;
and written by Sam and his brother Ivan
The fourth film on our list is
[REC].
With a perfect blend of both style
and substance,
directors Jaume Balaguero and Paco Plaza set out to create a classic horror movie,
but to tell the story more like a TV show.
[REC] unfolds in real-time and
attempts to immerse the viewer in the experience
through the eyes of a TV reporter and her cameraman.
The production is sparse with an almost claustrophobic feel
where something horrifying and unknown is happening.
Number three is The Devil’s
Advocate.
We're talking about director Guy Green’s 1977 West German English-language film,
not the Keanu Reeves/Al Pacino film of the same name.
'The Devil’s Advocate' tells the story of a Roman Catholic priest
The priest is sent to a remote Italian village to play devil’s advocate
in the investigation of a man who is a candidate to be canonized by the church.
At number two we have Roman Polanski’s classic psychological horror film
'Rosemary’s Baby'.
Centering around Rosemary Woodhouse, a young housewife who,
along with her husband, moves into a fancy apartment building where strange things begin to happen
When she wakes with scratch marks all over her body
and soon receives news that she is pregnant, things take a decidedly evil turn.
Which brings us to number one on our list.
It’s The Exorcist. William Friedken’s 1973 masterpiece
that was the first horror film to be nominated for the Best Picture Academy Award.
The head-turning, vomit-spewing, demonically possessed 12-year-old girl
ith a serious potty mouth is pretty much Hollywood’s gold standard
for evil personified.
And there you have it, our Top Five favorite religious-horror movies.
And that should be perfect to get you ready to check out our film, 'Jeruzalem'.
It tells the story of two young American women who travel to Tel Aviv
for a vacation, but are persuaded to change their plans by a young archeologist.
And pretty soon, all hell breaks loose
and they find themselves in the middle of a biblical apocalypse.
I’m Yoav and this is my brother Doron for Fandango Movieclips.
Be sure to check out 'Jeruzalem' in theaters now.